das ist ne maus geil aber die verbinde
ich die denn wer denkt sich denn bitte
so mit kaka aus wer braucht das
und wer kauft ist dann außer ich jetzt
ich mache ja nur fürs video etwas
gedacht und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja seit ich auch
natürlich euch jetzt gut machst du mir
jetzt gab es aufgefallen die auf hama
kamen maschine so an die müssen wir
erstmal aus wir wollen keine
störgeräusche hier in meinen videos
leute was gedacht ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut mir auch das heutige video
also ich bin gestern was heißt auf die
idee also kann man das erst ideen auf
jeden fall schauen ja sehr viele von
euch meinen kanal sehr gerne weil ich
immer irgendwelche sachen bestellen
vieles aus china von irgendwelchen
online shops die auspacke euch zeigen
und über diesen zeitraum
du kannst ja gerne mal hin auf dieses
auf diese wand film ja das hier ist der
wand die hat also sieht aus wie früher
im kinderzimmer so eigentlich aber wir
sind in unserem wohnzimmer
hier arbeiten wir dann immer und
schneiden und wir sind halt so ganz
viele paket von acht drin hier auch
alles voll hier auf wir legen die eier
objekte die haben wir noch er hat also
die wahl sei aber ein paar sind der weg
davon also weil die verlost wurden auf
jeden fall habe ich das gestern alles
noch so ein bisschen sortiert weil hier
flogen bestimmt noch reichlich
verschiedene artikel rum und bei vielen
muss ich halt gar nicht was da drin ist
das ding ist nämlich immer wenn ich
etwas bestelle das kommt dann natürlich
mal an und dann denke ich ok alle sachen
sind da ich pack das aus zeigt euch das
und irgendwas fehlt dann davon noch um
irgendwas habe ich dann vergessen was
ich auch noch gestellt habe was dann
wochen später ankommt und so häufen sich
dann als sachen
wo ich keinen plan hat was das ist wie
zb bei diesen hier wir haben hier
insgesamt neun verschiedene artikel dass
sie haben schon mal aufgemacht um rein
zu schauen aber der rest ist ein
wirklich alles zu und das hier auch
nicht naja gut also dass im neuen sachen
kleinere sachen wahrscheinlich vieles
von kostenlose produkte von newmont wo
ich keinen plan und wäre ja schade wenn
wir direkt schmeißen
deswegen habe ich gedacht machen was ein
kleines mystery amdocs ihn raus weil ich
halt keinen plan hat was drin ist und
ich will gar nicht gern aber daumen nach
oben für die tolle idee
das hatte juwi so damit der mystery
dingen gut und willst du mal eingreifen
einmal so erstes produkt vielleicht
erinnere ich mich ja dann auch wieder
daran wenn ich es auch machen
ein auto habe ich ein auto bestellt ist
es nicht der computermaus
stimmt das ist ne maus ja geil aber ich
verbinde ich die dann kennst du sowas ja
ich nur legen man muss nur ein kleiner
usb stick sein und dadurch trocknet man
sonst gibt es saures mustern bestimmt
lassen wir das weißt du was ich mich
jetzt nur noch frage genauso wie bei den
ballons team bei diesem jungen an boxen
dann habe ich etwas bestellt das muss
man dann noch wissen und ich kann mich
nicht daran erinnern dass ich jemals
irgendwie ein auto gestellt hat ich kann
meine ganzen bestellung sehen wenn ich
das irgendwie finde werde ich sie ein
aber ich habe keine ahnung kommt vom 22
geschichten aus spenden die der mutlos
jetzt aus dem ausland
nein nein okay leute machen wir weiter
nächstes produkt ja habe ich schon mal
sagte ich gerade
weißt du was ist bitte ich glaube knete
die hüften kann knete die hübsche warum
habe ich irgendwo bei jugend glaube ich
gesehen und habe ich direkt zugeschlagen
hat halt nur 1 euro gekostet kommt aus
niederaula kommt nicht aus china kommt
aus deutschland
naja das portmonee oder sechsmal mal
anfassen sondern war als das schon
komisch ich will einmal dass es gegen
die mannschaft nicht aber ist eigentlich
galt also eine greater gefällt mir
danke danke okay machen wir weiter
zauberwürfel ich weiß ich habe keine
ahnung was das ist das hab ich mich
letztens schon gefragt das standort drin
in diesen dingen und ich kann's nicht
zuordnen ich habe vom 17
also schon vier monate her dass ich das
bestellt hat das kommt aus china
[Applaus]
ich weiß was es ist das ist
unterwasserbeleuchtung warum warum
und zwar hatte ich eigentlich mal vor
ich wollte cool cats testen und da habe
ich das gestellt also das kann man halt
gemacht haben sich auf einmal läuft dann
nicht mehr so nah das bedeutet sondern
legt auch solle muss draufstehen
dann denke ich mal was hier an
verstehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz das
ding sechs bis acht stunden acht die
scheiße verkauften so was du machst du
was solchen damit ist also sogar sonne
scheint dann sollen sie lieber eine
batterie dazu gelegen
ich verstehe es insofern dass wenn man
es man legt es einfach im pool dann rein
dann strahlt die ganze zeit die sonne
drauf und irgendwann leuchtet nachts das
ist auf jeden fall wirklich von bush
gewesen wenn ich mir sicher machen wir
mal weiter
ich muss direkt sagen es ist ziemlich
leicht also als wäre da gar nichts drin
aber irgendwas ist drin
deswegen schauen wir direkt mal rein ich
weiß nicht ich weiß nicht was das ist
wer denkt sich denn bitte so mit kaka
aus wer braucht das
und wer kauft es dann außer ich jetzt
ich mache ja nur fürs video
du kannst mir doch nicht erzählen das
ist also bitte das ohne scheiß habe ja
noch nie gesehen und dann steht hier
auch noch irgendwas von vitamin oder
tabletten drauf naja es ist eine lustige
idee das muss man sagen kaputt ich weiß
nicht also absolut unnötig meiner
meinung nach aber ich glaube ich kann
mich aber auch daran erinnern dass habe
ich wenn ich das bestellt aber es ist
schon ein bisschen länger her aber es
war auch irgendwie was von kostenlosen
produkten oder so naja mal schauen was
uns noch erwartet ein wasser thermometer
juli soll der kamera und schüttelt nur
den kopf was mach ich will mal was
ausprobieren meinte das kann man auch
zum fiebermessen testen 35 grad
die schenke ich dir lieber messen
ich glaube dass wir auch für coole
gadgets ich weiß nicht oder hat als
fieberthermometer ich gehe mal kurz in
der mund ausspülen aber guck mal die war
echt nett die haben gleich zwei mit
reingelegt das doch echt nicht schlecht
so mal schauen was noch auf mich wartet
das ist nicht irgendein schmetterling
dann hängt man auch nicht fliehen
ja doch klar ich hoffe einfach dass
eingetroffen so ich habe ihn jetzt mal
hier in meiner kampfmaschine befestigt
der passt jetzt ein bisschen auf die auf
und sie gleich viel schöner aus
das produkt toll da freue ich mich
drüber ok dann machen wir mal weiter
wir haben noch ein paar sachen ja wir
können die led-lampe rente aber wir
wollten jetzt eigentlich mit einer einen
rahmen für dich auch mal bei uns
bestellt hat verknüpfen allerdings habe
ich glaube ich weggeschmissen
und was soll ich euch jetzt auch
kurzzeitig habe keinen kann warum ich
das immer mal bestellt habe und für was
das war
aber gut wir haben noch ein paar sachen
die bestimmt bruder sind und zwar dass
hier
da kannst du glaubst anfang ich weiß
nicht was es ist
starting pad das brauchen wir doch für
die airports und wenn wir die testen
deswegen test noch einmal kurz auf das
geht
[Musik]
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 haben wir schon neun
ausgepackt scheint so also darauf
jedenfalls überaus drin ja gut dann ist
das also
dann macht es jetzt gar keinen sinn mit
am ende des videos weil wir sind ja
schon am ende des videos leute ich weiß
das weil es kein mega mega cooles video
aber ich wollte euch die ganze sache
noch zeigen vielleicht ist ja für jeden
etwas dabei und war ja ganz interessant
auch für uns immerhin habe ich jetzt
alles ausgepackt und weiß um was es sich
handelt lassen doch nach oben da morgen
mal zu sehen wir uns wieder gibt's neues
video aber hier den kanal glock
aktivieren
haut rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]